dames rire
guy andré responsable de gare dans l'est
à saint-andré et saint-benoît ma
fonction c'est faire les demandes de
cartes et renseigner les gens
voir concernant les abonnements qu'on
fait pour les moins de 26 ans et sinon
pour les seniors est libre circulation
ces quarante étudiants ils font en ligne
quand ils font sur internet directement
ils viennent retirer dans dans les gares
et c'est nous qui le font pas alors on
bonnet responsable de belles équipes
on va dire ça d'une douzaine de
personnes il ya deux personnes le matin
de l'après midi que ce soit à s'attendre
et où il joue simplement là aujourd'hui
mallet à saint-andré demain melia saint
benoît
ben moi c'est tout le contact
les gens et bombe à tout le personnel
est question mais moi les jeunes et
moins jeunes qu'on l'ait à sa baignoire
ou à une clientèle à s'attendrir notre
clientèle et c'est ça qui me plaît c'est
le contact humain quoi
mais c'est aussi mon team et ses études
au petit moment jean lecomte s'amuser
famille nombreuse donc il fallait aller
travailler pour nourrir les chiffrait à
10 heures tous à abattre dans le milieu
dans le milieu musical en fin de compte
donc voila quoi c'est pas mal de
spectacles dans le temps à manger
notamment ma gynéco monde comme disait
moi je note s'était alors qu'à ce mal
allez pas très loin de sa salle verte
quant à épiler sens inverse tout ça là
je ne permets moi de voyager de dettes
s'accumulent et aujourd'hui enfin
content d'avoir le contact assez
facilement et de falaises bain pour
accueillir les gens pour les aider
et puis voilà
la musique la réunion vide de la musique
n'est pas prévu dans le bon donc après
j'ai entendu qu'il cherchait des
personnes pour pouvoir travailler dans
le transport ben je me suis inscrit et
ça ça m'a plu et bon voila si jusqu'à
maintenant puisque vingt ans que je suis
dans le métier et ça me plaît beaucoup
et je suis là et j'espère prendre ma
retraite adam sip étage est bon on a un
réseau qui fonctionne bien on a des
véhicules au top aujourd'hui est d'aider
des horaires plus souvent respectée a
donc voila moi mon mon souhait c'est
d'avoir des voies réservées que pour les
cars jaunes là qu'on va voir les
bouchons à côté ils vont dire oh là où
on va mettre la voiture la case faut
essayer de prendre un petit peu l'écart
en sachant que bientôt il y aura à
étages aussi pourquoi pas ça c'est mon
souhait en vrai c'est pas donc combien
d'années